YOU PROBABLY WON'T BE SURPRISED
BUT WE HAVE CONFIRMATION TONIGH
TONIGHT.
WHEN THE SENATE DECIDED TO DELAY
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION
VOTE FOR A WEEK IN ORDER TO
ENABLE AN FBI INVESTIGATION,
EVERYONE WHO WAS NOT JEFF FLAKE
UNDERSTOOD THE POINT OF IT.
THE INVESTIGATION ITSELF WAS
IRRELEVANT.
FOR DEMOCRATS THE ONLY PURPOSE
WAS TO BUY TIME SO THAT NEW
PEOPLE, SOME OF THIS ANONYMOUSLY
COULD MAKE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
KAVANAUGH.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED AND
WE'VE BEEN THE FIRST TO SCOFF AT
SOME OF THESE CLAIMS BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THEM FRIVOLOUS, SOME OF
THEM ABSURD.
TONIGHT WE MUST TELL YOU A NEW
AND TROUBLING STORY HAS EMERGED
THAT COULD ALTER THE TRAJECTORY
OF NOT SIMPLY THE KAVANAUGH
NOMINATION BUT THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S A STORY OF A YOUNG MAN
OUTWARDLY RESPECTABLE BUT SO
MORALLY DISTORTED WITHIN, SO
ADDLED BY CHRONIC DEPENDENCY ON
DRAFT BEER, THE WITNESSES SAY HE
COMMITTED A PARTICULARLY HEINOUS
FORM OF ASSAULT IN A PUBLIC
PLACE.
THIS MAN, THIS MONSTER IN HUMAN
FORM ONCE TAUGHT THAT ICE CUBE
AT SOMEONE IN A BAR.
AN ICE CUBE, THE PERFECT WEAPON.
IN SOLID FORM, DEADLY.
AND THEN WITHIN HOURS IT MELTS
AND EVAPORATES INTO THE AIR, ALL
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE TURNS TO VAPO
VAPOR.
THERE ARE NO FINGERPRINTS, IT IS
DIABOLICAL, THERE PERFECT CRIME.
FROM A CONSTITUTIONAL
STANDPOINT, IT IS DISQUALIFYING.
WE'LL CONCEDE WE MISSED THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS STORY AT
FIRST BUT THE OTHER NETWORKS
WERE ON A TOO LONG BEFORE WE
WERE, WATCH THEIR COVERAGE.
>> DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT BRETT
KAVANAUGH THROUGH ICE IN
SOMEONE'S FACE >> THROUGH ICE IN
SOMEONE'S FACE.
>> ACCUSED HIM OF THROWING ICE.
>> THE NOMINEE THROUGH ICE ON
HIM.
>> ACCUSED HIM OF THROWING ICE
ON HIM FOR SOME UNKNOWN REASON.
>> Tucker: ICE GATE.
THE FOUNDERS AND FRAMERS OF THE
CONSTITUTION ANTICIPATED THIS
VERY MOMENT.
ARTICLE THREE, IN WORDS WELL
KNOWN TO EVERY FIRST-YEAR LAW
STUDENT, UNEQUIVOCAL ON THE
SUBJECT.
WHOEVER SHALL THROW ICE IN A
TAVERN IS DISQUALIFIED FROM
SERVICE IN THE FEDERAL
JUDICIARY."
A FORMER YEAR      EL STUDENT WO
OVERLAPPED WITH BRETT KAVANAUGH
IN SCHOOL, HAS CONTACTED THE FBI
WITH A NEW OUTRAGE.
ONE TIME AT A FRAT PARTY, SOME
FRATERNITY BROTHERS HIRED A TO
PUT ON SOME KIND OF SHOW.
WHAT DOES THIS HAVE TO DO WITH
BRETT KAVANAUGH?
AS HE CONCEDES, NOTHING.
I CAN'T SAY FOR CERTAIN THAT HE
WAS PRESENT IN THE FRAT HOUSE.
AND YET, THIS IS THE CRITICAL
PART OF THIS STORY.
BRETT KAVANAUGH MAY HAVE BEEN IN
THE STATE OF CONNECTICUT WHEN
THIS HAPPENED.
THE VERY SAME STATE AT THE VERY
SAME TIME THAT PEOPLE IN A
FRATERNITY HOUSE WERE DOING
THINGS THAT HE DIDN'T LIKE.
NEED WE SAY MORE?
TOTALLY AND UTTERLY
DISQUALIFYING.
STILL CONFUSED?
WATCH CNN THEY WILL EXPLAIN.
JULIE SWETNICK CLAIMS THAT 37
YEARS AGO FOR SOME REASON SHE
WENT TO TEN GANG RATE PARTIES IN
A ROW AND THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
MAY HAVE BEEN AT SOME OF THEM.
WHAT DID HE DO AT THESE PARTIES?
JULIE SWETNICK SIGNED A SWORN
STATEMENT THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
AND FRIENDS ADDED DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL TO THE PUNCH.
THAT'S A SERIOUS CHARGE BUT AS
SWETNICK EXPLAINED IN A
TELEVISED INTERVIEW, SHE DIDN'T
MEAN IT.
>> I SAW HIM AROUND THE PUNCH --
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE DID.
I SAW HIM BUY THEM.
SPAY WHAT YOU'VE HEARD DEMOCRATS
TALK A LOT RECENTLY ABOUT HOW HE
MAY HAVE LIED UNDER OATH.
THERE IS NOW QUITE A BIT OF
EVIDENCE THAT JULIE SWETNICK
JUST DID.
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE, THEY
AREN'T INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT
BECAUSE WHATEVER WORKS, POWER IS
THE POINT.
THEY SHOULD CARE, SEXUAL ASSAULT
IS A HORRIFYING CRIME NO MATTER
WHO COMMITS IT, ALL DECENT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT.
FALSE CLAIMS TRIVIALIZE THE
OFFENSE AND THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF WIDELY PUBLICIZED
FALSE CLAIMS OVER THE PAST 15
YEARS.
THEY UNDERMINED THE MANY ASSAULT
VICTIMS WHO ARE TELLING THE
TRUTH.
THEY MAKE THE SEARCH FOR JUSTICE
SEEMED POLITICAL AND WORST OF